y en mi nombre y toda nuestra familia
quiero agradecerle a ustedes por estar
aquí Hoy es una ocasión muy especial y
es un lugar muy especial ustedes y todos
los que están observando son el corazón
el alma de este increíble movimiento del
mayor país en la historia del mundo es
así de simple
nunca ha habido algo parecido este gran
movimiento no eso nunca ha habido nada
parecido y posiblemente jamás lo haya
nunca ha habido nada que compita con lo
que nosotros todos hemos logrado
[Aplausos]
damas y caballeros invitados
distinguidos compañeros ciudadanos
Estados Unidos El regreso de Estados
Unidos empieza ahora
[Música]
hace dos años cuando abandoné el cargo
los Estados Unidos estaban listos para
empezar una nueva era dorada nuestra
nación estaba en el pináculo de su poder
la prosperidad del prestigio
justo encima de todos los rivales todos
los enemigos y navegando hacia el futuro
con confianza y con mucha fuerza
y en cuatro años todo iba muy bien
hombres mujeres
estadounidenses asiáticos
todo el mundo le estaba yendo bien como
nunca antes
[Aplausos]
hubo un momento nunca como este
sabemos la página después de
globalistas tratos comerciales poco
beneficiosos
cuando el virus llegó a nuestro país
acciones
del mismo año Estados Unidos
encaminada
hacer la mejor recuperación económica en
la historia del mundo jamás registrada
qué tal les parece eso
todas las personas que venían en esta
administración todo lo que tenían que
hacer era simplemente sentarse y
observar la inflación no existía esa
frontera Sur por lejos era la frontera
más fuerte de todas y ya que la frontera
era fuerte las drogas que estaban
entrando a la tasa más baja de hace
muchos años
después de décadas de cosas energéticos
que ascendía en Estados Unidos
finalmente había llegado El Sueño
imposible de la independencia energética
estadounidense
que se hubiera convertido rápidamente en
dominancia energética
[Aplausos]
por primera vez en la memoria china
realmente estaba
retrocediendo y eso no se había visto
antes porque los Estados Unidos estaban
superando los en cada frente y chile
estaba pagando miles de millones de
dólares en impuestos
los granjeros lo saben porque recibieron
28 mil millones de dólares de eso ningún
presidente había visto recibido un dólar
para nuestro país de China hasta que yo
llegué
estábamos recibiendo cientos de miles de
millones de dólares
muchas personas creen que por esto china
jugó un rol bastante activo en la
elección de 2020 y solamente lo estoy
diciendo
seguramente
en vez de que los trabajos y las
fábricas se fueran a China desde Estados
Unidos por primera vez estaban
abandonando China y viniendo a Estados
Unidos
[Aplausos]
estaban regresando
por nuestros cortes Fiscales los mayores
en la historia mayores que lo que hizo
Ronald Reagan y él hizo mucho
Corea del Norte estaban en orden Todo
estaba en orden ellos respetaban
respetaban a Estados Unidos y
honestamente Me respetaban a mí yo los
conocía bien
[Aplausos]
este califato agresivo de Isis que
ningún presidente pudo conquistar fue
acabado Por mío por otros y por otros
grandes guerreros en menos de tres
semanas y al Bagdad y su fundador fue
casado y asesinado
Corea del Norte no había lanzado
Corea del Norte no había lanzado un solo
misil balístico de alto de largo alcance
desde que mi colega el presidente Hace
tres años desarrollamos una relación y
eso es algo bueno no es algo malo es
algo bueno
muy muy Bueno de hecho porque Miren lo
que está pasando ahora mis oponentes me
hicieron ver como un guerrerista
solamente con una persona terrible que
iría inmediatamente a la guerra dijeron
durante la campaña 2016 que si me volvía
presidente jamás habría una guerra creo
que habría una guerra de semanas
y tendremos guerras como nunca antes
pasó de inmediato y pasaron décadas
pasaron décadas en una guerra el primer
presidente en hacerlo
por un largo periodo de tiempo
[Aplausos]
estaba en paz Estados Unidos estaba
prosperando nuestro país estaba en
camino
a un futuro increíble porque yo hice
unas promesas importantes algunos
estadounidense y a diferencia de otros
presidentes Yo sí las mantuve y las
mantuve
[Aplausos]
Muchas gracias
Pau nuestro liderazgo fuimos una nación
gloriosa y grande algo que no han oído
por un largo periodo de tiempo
éramos una nación muy fuerte mucha más
importante tenemos una nación libre pero
ahora somos una nación
fracasando para millones estadounidenses
los últimos dos años bajo Joe biden han
sido un momento de dolores dificultad de
ansiedad y desesperación
mientras hablamos la inflación es la
mayor en más de 15 años los precios de
la gasolina han incrementados punto más
alto en la historia y pueden esperar que
vayan a subir más ahora que
estratégicas que yo llene han sido
drenadas virtualmente con el fin de
mantener esos precios más bajos justo
antes de la elección
intencionalmente ha rendido a nos ha
llegado la independencia energética no
hay ni siquiera la idea de que haya
dominancia ahora estamos rogando por
ayudar energética a otras naciones
exageras muchas
nos consideran detestables nuestra
frontera Sur ha sido eliminada de
nuestro país haciendo invadido por
millones y millones de personas
desconocidas muchos que están ingresando
por razones malas y siniestras si
ustedes saben Cuáles son esas razones
estaremos pagando un gran precio por
esta invasión nuestro país por muchos
años
cientos de miles de libras de drogas
mortales incluyendo
fentanol bastante letal están inundando
nuestro país
las calles ensangrentadas
de otros países explican que esto es lo
que Estados Unidos y las democracias
me están buscando hacer
Estados Unidos
debilitado y todo el mundo lo está
viendo los desastres en Afganistán
posiblemente el momento más avergonzante
de la historia de nuestro país donde
perdimos vidas dejamos a los
estadounidenses atrás y rendimos 85 mil
millones de dólares de equipo militar
y bueno Ucrania que nunca habría
ocurrido si yo fuese el presidente Esto
es algo
[Aplausos]
y bueno incluso los demócratas lo
admiten eso es algo que los he visto
admitir una y otra vez
pero nuestros enemigos están hablando de
nosotros con
tan felices porque todos estos eventos
ocurrieron Pero hay muchos más Incluso
hoy un misil fue enviado posiblemente
por parte de Rusia Apolonia
50 millones al interior de Polonia y la
gente
está enloqueciendo
no está nada felices están bastante
enojados ahora tenemos a un presidente
que se queda dormido en conferencias
globales
sorprendido y que fue atacado por el
parlamento británico después de la
Afganistán gracias a las palabras de
sabiduría que él dijo gracias agradeció
el país equivocado por invitarle una
Cumbre importante sobre el clima
vuelan por días para llegar allá y ahora
les dice
le dice al país
Bueno un nombre de un país que no estaba
ni siquiera en ese continente y nos está
llevando al borde de la guerra nuclear
un concepto inimaginable hace nada más
dos años
no se puede mencionar esa palabra es
demasiado basado
trato verde del tema del medio ambiente
que nos puede afectar de aquí a 300 años
de lo único que se habla y las armas
nucleares que podrían destruir el mundo
de inmediato ni siquiera se discuten
como una amenaza importante pueden
imaginarse eso Ellos dicen que el océano
se elevará un octavo de pulgada Durante
los próximos 200 o 300 años pero no se
preocupen por las armas nucleares que
pueden acabar con países entre los con
un solo disparo hay algo que está mal
con su pensamiento con el pensamiento
demócratas radicales Estados Unidos ha
sido burlada ha sido llevada a sus
rodillas posiblemente como nunca antes
pero estamos aquí hoy para declarar
que no tiene que ser de esa manera no
tiene que ser de esta manera
[Aplausos]
hace dos años éramos una gran nación y
muy pronto
Seremos una gran nación de nuevo
[Aplausos]
el declive de Estados Unidos está siendo
forzado por byden y por los lunáticos de
la izquierda que maneja nuestro gobierno
y que lo están llevando el suelo Este
declive
no es una tendencia que debemos afectar
cuando se nos dé la posibilidad
directamente usadamente creo que el
pueblo estadounidense
para esa plataforma izquierda nacional y
levantará nuestra plataforma de grandeza
y gloria nacional para Estados Unidos
Gloria
[Aplausos]
exactamente hace una semana nuestro
ciudadanos votaron en las elecciones
después de una periodo innecesario
ridículo de espera muchos mayores
cualquier otro país el tercer mundo
solamente un momento pequeño de los
estadounidenses recuperaron el control
de la cámara de representantes
[Aplausos]
con un gran respaldo por parte de Trump
el congresista Kevin Klein
una persona fantástica una persona
fantástica
me alegra mucho que haya sido su voto al
que lo haya logrado acabamos de
recuperar eso bueno Esto nos acabamos de
tener hace una hora hay muchas críticas
sobre el hecho que el partido
republicano debió haberlo hecho mejor y
francamente mucha esta culpa es correcta
pero los ciudadanos de nuestro país No
han entendido en ese momento la gravedad
del dolor relaciones atravesando el
efecto total del sufrimiento está
empezando a sentirse ellos no lo sienten
todavía pero muy pronto va a pasar no
tengo ninguna duda de que de aquí a 2024
tristemente será una situación mucho
peor y van a verlo mucho más claro lo
que ha pasado y lo que le está pasando y
las votaciones van a ser mucho más
diferentes de aquí 2024
están alistándose ustedes
[Aplausos]
Porque yo sí me estoy alistando yo estoy
alistándome
quiero señalar que las elecciones
recientes
mi tasa de éxito el respaldos fue 232
victorias eso solamente 22 derrotas uno
no escucha eso de los medios
y Esta es una noche elegante y una
prensa elegante está en el lugar no voy
a utilizar el término noticias falsas
Así que vamos a mantenerlo elegante pero
ustedes no escuchan eso de los medios y
creo que lo van a escuchar porque la
gente empieza a ver lo que ha pasado en
las primarias fue de
98.6%. pero todavía estaban intentando
culparme y la razón de este éxito
que no tenía precedentes Es que la
administración de Trump cambió nuestra
nación en el comercio en la seguridad de
la frontera con la frontera más segura y
más fuerte la historia de nuestro país
sobre el terrorismo islámico
prácticamente
no puedo pensar no tuvimos ningún ataque
islámico terrorista durante la
administración de Trump y de hecho nos
fue muy bien con diversos países
[Aplausos]
Incluyendo
los acuerdos de Abraham son unas cosas
maravillosas el acuerdo
pero es por el recorte de impuestos el
corte de regulaciones En los niveles más
altos
y en la construcción de la mayor
economía en cualquier momento de la
historia del mundo nunca ha habido una
economía como la que estuvimos hace dos
años a pesar del resultado en el senado
no podemos perder esperanza y todos
tenemos que trabajar muy muy duro
un caballero una persona conocida
hombre maravilloso fantástico que conoce
nuestro país y que será un gran senador
de nuestro país
pueden salir y votar porque él se lo
merece
fue un atleta increíble y será Incluso
un mejor senador vayan a votar por
ejercer Walker
elegimos a un grupo
de líderes de América estrellas de
nuestro país de aquí a muchos
voto popular otra cosa que no se discute
para la cámara debemos recordar que los
republicanos ganaron
5 millones de votos más el mayor margen
en muchos años por encima de los
demócratas son cinco millones de votos
más dice algo muy importante estar
rompiendo con el control de los
demócratas radicales en el congreso en
otras palabras debido a nuestros grandes
congresistas a todos nuestros
congresistas hombres y mujeres nos hemos
tomado el congreso Nancy pelosi ha sido
ha sido despedida
[Aplausos]
les dije a usted Bueno si pueden
mantener un estándar más bajo puede
tener una victoria grande dijeron vamos
a ganar por 48 200 si ustedes ganan por
dos asientos tiendas de feliz pero ella
está en camino a otro país en estos
momentos
ha sido despedida
pero siempre hemos sabido
que el fin que era solamente el inicio
de nuestra lucha para rescatar el sueño
estadounidense
y es una palabra que no se utiliza son
dos palabras no quiero ser Joe biden son
dos palabras sueño americano
digo muchas cosas malas como ir a ida o
decir bienvenidos al estado de Florida
realmente me Encanto
con el fin de hacer que Estados Unidos
sea más grande y más gloriosa de nuevo
ese anunciando hoy mi candidatura a la
presidencia de los Estados Unidos
muchas muchas gracias gracias a todos
[Aplausos]
tan tan amistades increíbles tanta
familia aquí es algo hermoso la gente
dice cómo puedes hablar frente a tanta
gente todo el tiempo Cuando hay amor en
la habitación es muy fácil
realmente es así
deberían intentarlo en algún momento
juntos estaremos asumiendo las fuerzas
más corruptas y los intereses más
implicados imaginables nuestro país está
en un estado horrible estamos en un
grado de peligro Esta no es una tarea
para un político para un candidato
convencional esa es una tarea para un
gran movimiento que incorpores la
confianza del espíritu del pueblo
estadounidense Este es un movimiento
Esto no es de un solo individuo hay un
trabajo y es un trabajo para decenas de
miles de millones de personas orgullosas
trabajando juntas de todo el país
jóvenes viejos hispanos asiáticos negros
gente que hemos reunido por primera vez
si ustedes observan a las cifras ven lo
que ha sucedido con los hispanos con los
hanfre estadounidenses con la comunidad
asiática si ustedes mira lo que está
pasando Este es un partido que se ha
convertido en algo más grande en algo
más fuerte algo mucho más poderoso y
pueda ser cosas mucho mejores por
nuestro país Este es un trabajo para las
abuelas para los trabajadores de
construcción para los bomberos para los
constructores profesores granjeros que
no pueden crearse callados ya no pueden
quedarse en silencio ustedes están
enojados por lo que está pasando en
nuestro país está siendo destruido ante
sus propios ojos es un trabajo para cada
joven aspirante para cada padre
trabajador para cada emprendedor para
cada oficial de policía que no está
siendo apreciado que está listo para
gritar exigir la seguridad porque la
policía está siendo tan maltratada son
personas increíbles pueden acabar son
los que saben cómo hacerlo Tenemos que
darles el respeto y la dignidad que se
merecen de vuelta
esta no va a ser mi campaña estaba a ser
nuestra campaña de todos nosotros
[Aplausos]
Porque la única fuerza tan fuerte para
para vencer la corrupción que estamos
enfrentando ustedes el pueblo
estadounidense es así el pueblo
estadounidense el mejor pueblo sobre la
Tierra los amamos a todos llevamos a
ambos lados vamos a reunir a la gente
vamos a unificar a la gente y eso ya
estaba ocurriendo en la anterior
administración anterior al anterior
lo que nos estaba reuniendo fue el éxito
antes de que el Kobe llegara las
personas estaban llevándome que me
estaban llamando ustedes no lo
entenderían este están a la izquierda
Pese que jamás me hablarían y yo jamás
les hablaría pero nuestro éxito fue tan
Increíble como nunca antes y luego el
covid empezó a llegar desde china les
llamamos el virus chino algunas personas
le dicen otras cosas pero fue devastador
reconstruimos hicimos un trabajo
increíble cuando la gente dice el
republicanos o demócratas o liberales o
con
yo digo que podemos reunirnos estábamos
haciéndolo eso estaba pasando justo
antes porque el éxito
fue mayor que este país había tenido
estábamos superando a China superando a
todo el resto y todo el mundo quería una
parte de ese pastel
[Aplausos]
Pero así como lo prometí en 2016 yo soy
su voz Yo soy su voz
[Aplausos]
el establecimiento en Washington quiere
silenciarlos pero no les permitiremos
hacer eso lo que hemos construido juntos
en los últimos seis años es el mayor
movimiento de la historia porque no se
trata de la política se trata de nuestro
amor por este gran país Estados Unidos y
no vamos a dejar que fracase
[Aplausos]
yo estoy aspirando porque creo que el
mundo no ha visto todavía la gloria
verdadera de lo que esta nación puede
ser no Hemos llegado ese pináculo
creando uno
y de hecho podemos ir mucho más allá y
vamos a tener que ir más allá primero
Tenemos que salir de esta trinchera
Entonces no se imaginan lo que podemos
lograr en ningún país es posible pero
aquí es posible los Estados Unidos es un
país increíble
[Aplausos]
somos estadounidenses y no tenemos que
soportar lo que ha ocurrido en
Washington DC este es nuestro país es
nuestro gobierno y
bueno Los Dueños del poder bueno
el poder es nuestro
nosotros estamos
en camino a tomarnos este poder de nuevo
[Aplausos]
aquí hasta el día de la elección en 2024
que llegará rápidamente miren como vuela
el tiempo miren lo rápido que ha pasado
todo yo voy a luchar como nunca nadie ha
luchado antes
vamos a vencer los demócratas radicales
de la izquierda que están intentando
destruir a nuestro país desde el
interior y así en los protegeré nos
protegeré Yo quiero nosotros tenemos que
ser protegidos de todas esas naciones
que están allá afuera que está buscando
destruirlos desde Más allá de nuestras
costas hay muchas naciones que nos odian
gravemente y ese es el problema cuando
nos miran en el desorden en el que
estamos ahora que vamos allá a pedirles
petróleo Y tenemos mucho más petróleo
que el que ellos tienen o que cualquier
otra nación tiene y no lo utilizamos
porque vamos a hablar con ellos es una
locura lo que ha estado pasando no
podemos permitir que siga pasando Joe
biden es la cara del este caso de la
izquierda y de la corrupción de
Washington Tuvo una cena del g20 muy
importante todo el mundo voló desde
donde sea donde sea y miren jamás llegó
todavía lo están buscando se preguntan
Dónde está el g20 me gustaban los
líderes solía hacer tratos para nuestro
país como no creerían había uno en el
otro del otro
y logramos que dejaran de tomar sus
ventajas cada país nos tomó ventaja
renegociamos estratos con México con
Canadá
acabamos con los peores tratados
acabamos con el nafta el peor el TL es
el peor Trato hecho
reclamar factores hicimos un trato
reestructuramos
reestructuramos nuestros tratos
terribles con Japón
un gran hombre desafortunadamente
era mi amigo amado muchos países de mi
amigo y logramos un trato increíble
Corea del Sur otros países y lo mejor
fue lo que hicimos con china
logramos otra técnica
hablo de eso por la voz por La
devastación que causó el mundo entero
fue demasiado
voy a asegurarme de que yo no reciba
cuatro años más en la presidencia
eso no puede pasar
[Aplausos]
nuestro país
no puede soportarlo más y lo digo no
riendo vecino en lágrimas no puede
soportar cuatro país mal solamente puede
soportar sigue siendo muy frágil
en 2020 recibi la mayor cantidad de
votos de cualquier presidente de la
historia
y fue un gran maestro
pero incluso con más votos en esta